Навчання українських розвідників на Донбасі.
Військові вправляються у стрільбі та навичках ведення бою парами.
Для бійців це - буденна справа.
Адже попри перемир'я вони завжди мають бути напоготові.
Незвично хіба що те, що серед них - дівчина.
Імітація виходу розвідувальної групи і контакту з противником.
Тобто це контрзасадні дії, які виконує група,
потрапляючи в засідку - під вогневий наліт.
Як і її товариші по службі, Анастасія не хоче показувати обличчя.
Бути впізнаними противником - занадто великий ризик для розвідників.
Анастасії - 25 років.
П'ять із них вона служить у війську.
В ЗСУ дівчина прийшла зі студентської лави - навчалась на програмістку.
Раніше з армією її ніщо не пов'язувало - навіть військових у родині не було.
З мого села їхали люди на війну -
вони гинули, вони не повертались.
Я бачила, як гинуть люди тут - цивільні і військові.
Я не могла залишатись осторонь.
Спочатку було важко потрапити до війська, тому що ти - жінка,
2015 рік, а все, що я мала за плечима -
це добра фізична підготовка, тому що я займалась спортом.
В трьох військових частинах мені відмовили.
Коли я прийшла в мою сьогоднішню військову частину,
я побачила приспущений прапор з чорною стрічкою.
Це символізувало те, що в бригаді
зовсім недавно загинуло багато людей
і бригада в траурі.
Я чітко усвідомлювала,
що моє життя зміниться, воно не буде легким,
але мені це потрібно - воно того варте.
У війську Анастасія спочатку стала радіотелефоністкою.
А згодом, після того, як Міністерство оборони у 2016 році
дозволило жінкам обіймати бойові посади, перевелась у розвідку.
У своєму розвідувальному підрозділі Анастасія - єдина жінка саме на бойовій посаді.
До того ж вона - старший сержант.
Тож під час навчань тренується не тільки сама -
ще й інструктує інших, як поводитись зі зброєю.
Зброю відводити від грудей. Не отак, не отак,
а коли саме вона іде від грудей -
у нас будуть більш точними постріли.
Це 5 балів, але мій рівень має бути, скажімо так, трошки вищим.
Минулого року я виграла змагання на першість бригади -
результат був трошки кращим.
Мені ще є над чим працювати, є що тренувати.
Ну, поки що результат, скажімо так - я задоволена, командир не насварив.
Анастасія розповідає, що з самого початку поставила собі за мету
стати у військовій справі не гіршою, ніж чоловіки у розвідувальному підрозділі.
Щоправда, згадує вона, спершу це видавалось недосяжним.
Я зрозуміла - якщо мені дали дозвіл служити тут,
я повинна це виправдати.
Тому я відразу пояснила особовому складу без слів -
своїми діями, що я справлюсь.
Я сама, мені не потрібна допомога.
Вже після двох місяців служби в підрозділі мені
не подавали руку на БТР,
мені не допомагали нести мої речі,
мене не пропускали в черзі.
Я стояла в черзі в душ, в їдальню - так, як і всі.
Вони спостерігали за мною - я дуже старалась, не хотіла їх підвести,
і, нарешті, наступив той час, коли я вийшла з ними на один рівень,
коли для них вже стала звичною моя присутність і моя робота.
Бути на одному рівні з досвіченими бійцями -
ефективний запобіжник проти дискримінації, пояснює Анастасія.
За роки наполегливої праці їй вдалось
завоювати довіру і повагу і підлеглих, і командирів.
Я бачив, як вона працює, як вона гарно керує особовим складом,
як вона чітко ставить кожному завдання - що кожному робити.
Люди їй довіряють і спокійно за нею ідуть.
Якби в армії було більше жінок, це було б непогано.
Жінки в армії - до якогось моменту це було незрозуміло,
наприклад, до 14-го року.
Але потім все почало ставати на свої місця,
ми перейняли досвід передових країн у військовій сфері.
Мабуть, більше відповідальності. Вони, напевно,
психологічно трохи більш стійкі.
Хоча жінку на війні можна відрізнити від чоловіка тільки
за одним чинником - фізіологічним і все.
Вони так само і стріляють,
і водять техніку, і стоять на постах,
і виконують різні завдання.
Для Анастасії військова справа вже стала професією.
Розвідниця каже, що зупинятись на досягнутому не збирається.
Планує і надалі розвиватись, прагне стати офіцеркою ЗСУ.